what i want to do in this video is
introduce you to the idea of the
covariance between two
between two random variables and it's
defined as
the expected value
the expected value of
the distance or i guess the product of
the distances of each random variable
from their
mean or from their expected value so let
me just write that down so if i take
expect i'll have x first i'll do this in
another color so it's the expected value
of random variable x minus the expected
value of x you could view this as the
population mean of x
times
and then this is random variable y so
times the distance from
y
to
its expected value or the population
mean
the population mean of y
the population mean of y and if it
doesn't make a lot of intuitive sense
yet well one you can just always kind of
think about what it's doing play around
with some numbers here
but the reality is it's saying how much
they vary together so you always take
two you an x and a y for each of the
data points let's see the whole
population so every x and y that kind of
that go together with each other that
are a coordinate you put into this and
what happens is let's say that x is
above its mean when y is below its mean
so let's say in the population you had
the point so one instantiation of the
random variables you have you sample
once i guess from the universe and you
get x
is equal to one and that y
and y is equal to
let's say y is equal to three and let's
say that you knew ahead of time you know
you knew ahead of time that the expected
value of x is zero and let's say that
the expected value
expected value of y is equal to four so
in this situation
what just happened now we don't know the
entire covariance we only have one
sample here for of this random variable
but what just happened here we have one
minus so we're just going to calculate
we're not going to calculate the entire
expected value i just want to calculate
what happens when we do what's inside
the expected value we'll have 1 minus a
0 so you'll have a 1
times a
3 minus 4 times a negative 1. so you
have one times negative one which is
negative one and what is that telling us
well it's telling us at least for this
sample this one time that we sampled the
random variables x and y
x was above
its expected value when y was below its
expected value and if we kept doing this
let's say for the entire population this
happened then it would make sense that
they have a negative covariance when one
goes up the other one goes down when one
goes down the other one goes up if they
both go up together they would have a
positive variance or they go both go
down together and and the degree to
which they do it together will tell you
kind of the magnitude of the covariance
hopefully that gives you a little bit of
intuition about what the covariance is
trying to tell us but the more important
thing that i want to do in this video is
to connect this formula
is i want to connect this definition of
covariance to everything we've been
doing with least squares regression and
really it's just kind of a fun math
thing to do to show you how well you
know to show you all of these
connections and where really the
definition of covariance really becomes
useful and i really do think it's
motivated to a large degree by uh where
it shows up in regressions and this is
all stuff that we've kind of seen before
you're just going to see it in a
different way so let's just i'm just
this whole video i'm just going to
rewrite this regret i'm just going to
rewrite this definition of covariance
right over here so this is going to be
the same thing so this is going to be
the same thing as the expected value
the expected value of and i'm just going
to multiply these two binomials in here
so the expected value of our random
variable x
times our random variable y
times our random variable y minus well
i'll just do the x first so plus x times
the negative expected value of y so i'll
just say minus
minus
x times the expected value of y
the expected value
of
y and that negative sign comes from this
negative sign right over here and then
we have minus expected value of x times
y
minus the expected value of x
times this y
this doing the distributed property
twice and then finally you have the
negative expected value of x times the
negative expected value of y and the
negatives cancel out and so you're just
going to have plus the expected value of
x
plus the expected value of x times the
expected value of y
times the expected value
of y and of course it's the expected
value of this entire thing
it's the expected value of this entire
thing now let's see if we can rewrite
this well the expected value of the sum
of a of a bunch of random variables or
the sum and difference of a bunch of
random variables is just the sum or
difference of their expected value so
this is going to be the same thing this
is going to be and remember expected
value in a lot of context you can view
it as just the arithmetic mean or in a
continuous distribution you could view
it as a probability weighted sum or
probability weighted integral either way
it's nothing we've seen it before i
think so let's rewrite this so this is
equal to the expected value of the
random variables x and y
x times y
trying to keep them color coded for you
color coded and then we have minus x
times the expected value of y so then
we're going to have minus the expected
value
minus the expected value of x
of x times expected value of y of x
times the expected value of y
you stay with the right colors
then you're going to have minus the
expected value of this thing minus the
expected value of
i'll close the parentheses of this thing
right over here expected value of x
expected value of x times y and this
might look really confusing with all the
embedded expected values but one way to
think about is the things that already
have the expected values you can kind of
view these as numbers you already view
them as known so we're actually going to
take them out of the expected value
because the expected value of an
expected value is the same thing as the
expected value actually let me write
this over here just to remind ourselves
the expected value
of the expected value of x
is just going to be the expected value
of x
of x think of it this way this is the
you could view this as the population
mean for the random variable so that's
just going to be a known it's out there
it's in the universe so the expected
value of that is just going to be itself
if if the population mean or the
expected value of x is five
this is like saying the expected value
of five well the expected value of five
is going to be five which is the same
thing as the expected value of x
hopefully that makes sense we're going
to use that in a second so we're almost
done we did the expected value of this
and we have one term left and then the
final term the expected value of this
guy and here we can actually use the
property right from the get go i'll
write it down so the expected value of
put some big brackets up of this thing
right over here
expected value of x
times the expected value of y
times the expected value of y let's see
if we can simplify it right here so this
is just going to be the expected value
of the product of these two random
variables i'll just leave that the way
it is so let me just the stuff that i'm
going to leave the way it is i'm just
going to kind of freeze them so the
expected value the expected value of x y
now what do we have over here we have we
have the expected value of x times once
again you can kind of view it if you go
back to what we just said is this is
just going to be a number expected value
of y so we can just bring this out if
this was the expected value of 3x it
would be the same thing as 3 times the
expected value of x so we could rewrite
this as negative
expected value of y
expected value
of y
times the expected value of x
times the expect so we kind of you can
kind of view this as we took it out of
the expected value we factored it out
so
just like that and then you have minus
same thing over here you can factor out
this expected value of x
minus
the expected value of x
times the expected value of y
let me write it
times the expected value of y this is
getting confusing with all the e's
laying around
and then finally you have the expected
value of this thing of two expected
values well that's just going to be the
product of those two expected values so
that's just going to be plus i'll freeze
this
expected value of
expected value of x
times
the expected value
of y
now what do we have here we have
expected value of y times the expected
value of x and then we are subtracting
the expected value of x times expected
value of y these two things are the
exact same thing right so this is going
to be and actually look at this we're
subtracting it twice and then we have
one more these these are all the same
thing this is the expected value of y
times expected value of x this is the
expected value of y times the expected
value of x just written a different
order and this is the expected value of
y times the expected value of x
we're subtracting it twice and then
we're adding it or one way to think
about it is that this guy and that guy
will cancel out you could have also
picked that guy in that guy but what do
we have left we have the covariance of
these two random variables x and y are
equal to the expected value of i'll
switch back to my colors just because
this is the final result the expected
value of x
times the expected value of the product
of x y
the expected value of
the product the expected value of the
product
minus
minus what is this the expected value of
y
the expected value of y
times the expected value of x
times the expected value of x now if you
know you can calculate these expected
values if you know everything about the
probability distribution or density
functions for each of these random
variables or if you have the entire
population that you're sampling from
whenever you take an instantiation of
these random variables let's say you
just had a sample of these random
variables how could you estimate them
how could you estimate them
well if you if you were estimating it
the expected va the expected value
let's say you just have a bunch of data
points a bunch of coordinates and i
think you'll start to see how this
relates to what we did with regression
the expected vary the expected the
expected value of
x times y it can be approximated by the
sample mean of x and of the products of
x and y
this is going to be the sample mean of x
and y you take each of your xy
associations take the product and then
take the mean of all of them so that's
going to be the product of x and y and
then this thing right over here the
expected value of y that can be
approximated by the sample
by the sample mean of y and the expected
value of x can be approximated by the
sample mean of x so what can this what
can the covariance of two random
variables be approximated by
what can they be approximated by well
this right here is the mean of their
product
from your sample
minus
the mean of your sample y's
minus the mean of your sample y's times
the mean of your sample x's
times the mean of your sample x's and
this should start looking familiar this
should look a little bit familiar
because what is this this was the
numerator
this right here is the numerator
this is the numerator when we were
trying to figure out the slope of the
regression line
so we tried to figure out the slope of
the regression line we had the let me
just rewrite the formula here just to
remind you it was literally
the mean of the products of each of our
data points
minus or the xy's minus the mean of y's
times the mean of the x's all of that
over
all of that over the mean
of the x squareds and you can even view
it as
this over the mean of the x times the
x's
but i can just write the x squareds over
here
minus
minus the mean
the mean of x squared this was
this is how we figured out the slope of
our regression line or maybe a better
way to think about it if we assumed in
our regression line that we we were the
points that we have were sample from an
entire universe of possible points then
you could say that we are approximating
the approximating the slope of our
regression line and you might see this
little hat notation in a lot of books
don't want to be confused or saying that
you're approximating the population's
regression line from a sample from a
sample of it now this right here so
everything we've learned right now this
right here is the covariance or this is
an estimate of the covariance of x and y
now what is this over here
well i just said you could rewrite this
very easily as so this bottom part right
here you could write as the mean of x
times x that's the same thing as x
squared
minus
minus the mean of x times the mean of x
right that's what the mean of x squared
is
what's this well you could view this as
the covariance the covariance of x
with x but we already we've actually
already seen this and i've actually
shown you
many many videos goes when we first
learned about it what this is the
covariance of a random variable with
itself is really just
the variance
is really just the variance of that
random variable and you could verify it
for yourself if you take if you change
this y to an x this becomes x minus the
expected value of x times x minus the
expected value of x or that's the
expected value of x minus the expected
value of x squared that's your
definition of variance
so our
another way of thinking about the slope
of our regression line it can be
literally viewed as the covariance
of our two random variables over the
variance
over the variance of
over the variance of x or you can kind
of view it as the independent random
variable that right there is the slope
of our regression line anyway i thought
that was interesting and i wanted to
make connections between things you see
in different parts of statistics and
show you that there they really are
connected